[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers
imbalance in the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
we're gonna form a super-duper really
Needham topic morally flexible and young
enough to carry their own franchise for
10 to 12 years
x-force isn't that a little derivative
you're absolutely right I might be the
only person
who knows
what you really are
[Music]
what's that as you know parole and a
privilege it's a mistake but it happened
and if I were to be released I would um
[Music]
I would just want the simple life I just
wanna hold down a job make some friends
you know pay my bills I couldn't have
done this if you haven't taken over so
well I've got to succeed so she can
succeed
can she get it Bob is tricky but I can't
keep giving him cookies nobody
[Music]
the precedence adding drug cartels to
the list of terrorist organizations you
can understand how that will expand our
ability to combat them you want to see
this thing through I'm gonna have to get
dirty dirty is exactly why you're here
you're gonna help us start a war with
hope you just need someone watching your
back
like a partner
hold on you gave her wings and blasters
so I take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
what the hell is he doing find it best
not to hook
I don't like this I'll tell you anything
you wanna know I've never kept a secret
in my life
Audrey shaves between her boobs Morgan
flosses with her hair just extremes
about minions just the one minion with
the one eye she googled it on my
computer and now I get a lot of weird
ads
[Music]